Двічі позитивний і двічі негативний. Засновник SpaceX Ілон Маск в один день зробив чотири швидкі тести на антиген й отримав суперечливі результати.
Та сама машина, той самий тест і та сама медсестра, а зрозуміти, чи підчепив коронавірус, не вдалося. У чому проблема? І яким тестам довіряти?
У світі вже існує декілька сотень різноманітних тестів для виявлення коронавірусної інфекції.
Усі вони діляться за своїм принципом на три основні групи. Це ПЛР-тести, тести на антиген і тести на антитіла.
Нині це основний вид тестів. ПЛР розшифровується як полімеразна ланцюгова реакція.
Для виявлення коронавірусу беруть мазок з носа і горла ватною паличкою. Потім з генетичного матеріалу вилучають один ген, розмножують його,
багаторазово збільшуючи число його копій, і за допомогою певної біохімічної реакції визначають, чи є вірус у цьому генетичному матеріалі.
У багатьох країнах цей тест - єдина офіційна підстава визначати, хвора людина чи ні. ПЛР-тести вважаються найбільш надійними.
Але вірогідність помилки все одно висока. Близько третини тестів, за даними експертів, показують негативний результат, хоча людина вже інфікована.
Вірусолог берлінської клініки Charite Крістіан Дростен порівнює цей спосіб зі спробою виловити з акваріума сачком золоту рибку.
Якщо сачок виявився порожнім, це ще не означає, що в акваріумі немає риби.
Громадяни та жителі Німеччини, повертаючись додому після поїздки за кордон, можуть безкоштовно здати такий тест на коронавірус в аеропортах,
на залізничних вокзалах і в приватних лікарських практиках. В Україні ж безкоштовні ПЛР-тести роблять лише за направленням лікаря.
Власним коштом можна здати аналізи у державних та приватних лікарнях. Ціни на ПЛР-тести коливаються від 700-800 до двох з половиною тисяч гривень.
Вартість залежить, зокрема, від терміну виконання та того, чи викликали медпрацівника додому.
Стандартні ПЛР-тести проводяться в лабораторії, причому одночасно аналізується кілька тисяч проб.
Це означає, що пацієнтам іноді доводиться чекати результатів тесту кілька днів. Набагато швидше проводяться експрес-ПЛР-тести.
Тоді проби аналізуються за допомогою портативного приладу там, де вони були взяті. Тож результат можна отримати вже протягом 45 хвилин.
Недолік - прилад може обробити не більше 80 проб за добу.
Ця можливість виявити коронавірусну інфекцію з'явилася відносно недавно. Деякі виробники запевняють, що ці тести такі ж прості у застосуванні, як і тести на вагітність.
Але на практиці це не зовсім так. Для більшості експрес-тестів на коронавірус потрібен невеликий портативний пристрій для підготовки проби
для виявлення вірусу за допомогою ФІА. Це флуоресцентний імуноферментний аналіз. Тож у домашніх умовах не вийде.
Водночас для деяких експрес-тестів додаткові прилади не потрібні. Але цих тестів у більшості країн у вільному продажу немає.
Загалом тести на антиген проводяться за методикою ПЛР, коли у пацієнта ватною паличкою береться мазок з глотки.
Головна відмінність - час. Результат цього експрес-тесту відомий вже за 15 хвилин.
Проте він значно менш точний порівняно з ПЛР-тестами. Можна визначити лише кожного другого носія вірусу.
Попри це чимало лікарів виступають за масове застосування тестів на антиген, оскільки сподіваються, що це дозволить виявити більше тих, хто заразився.
Особливо так званих "суперпоширювачів", які мають найбільшу концентрацію вірусу і тому здатні заразити багатьох інших.
Експрес-тести на антиген в Україні поки що можна зробити в обмеженому переліку клінікі коштують ці тести 600-800 гривень.
Ці тести, як правило, роблять, щоб визначити, чи людина вже перехворіла на COVID-19.
Для цього потрібно взяти пробу крові для лабораторного аналізу.
Так само, як для визначення рівня цукру в крові у діабетиків, у пацієнта береться крапля крові і змішується з реагентом.
Якщо проба забарвлюється в інший колір, це означає, що людина вже перехворіла і в неї сформувався імунітет.
Але досі вивчається, скільки антитіла можуть триматися. За словами експертів, щонайменше три місяці, а далі індивідуально.
Антитіла класу G, які можна виявити в крові, починаючи з другого-третього тижня після інфекції, вказують, що людина раніше хворіла, але нині здорова.
А є ще антитіла класу М та А. Вони вказують, що людина ще інфікована.
Тести на антитіла в Україні коштують приблизно від 300 до 800 гривень. Але їхній результат, як і інших видів тестів, теж не завжди точний.
Позитивна реакція може бути і в тих, хто перехворів іншими коронавірусними інфекціями і не мав COVID-19.
У Фінляндії коронавірус у прямому розумінні винюхують собаки.
В аеропорту Гельсінкі триває пілотний проєкт з перехресною перевіркою результатів собак і медичних лабораторій.
Чотирилапі можуть виявити COVID-19 ще за п'ять днів до появи симптомів.
Причому з майже стовідсотковою точністю, запевняють місцеві ветеринарні дослідники.
Достатньо взяти простий мазок з зап'ястя чи шиї, або дати собаці понюхати хустинку, яку носили на шиї.
Собака одразу може просигналізувати, заразилася людина чи ні.
Такі тести значно швидші, ефективніші, дешевші та без дискомфорту, коли вам лізуть у ніс і горло ватною паличкою.
Головна проблема - швидко надресирувати величезну кількість собак. Крім того, не всі чотирилапі такі талановиті,
як цей собака Коссі, який показує відмінні результати у фінському аеропорту.
Зрештою, за даними Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров’я, тестування є найкращим способом діагностики коронавірусу.
Тобто, робити висновки потрібно не лише на підставі симптомів, а після лабораторного висновку.
Аби допомогти з тестуванням країнам з середніми та низькими доходами, у ВООЗ навіть вирішили надати їм 120 мільйонів нових швидких тестів.
Вони коштують дешевше, а результат видають швидше - за 13-30 хвилин. Ймовірно, що такі тести зможе отримати й Україна.